hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast syphilis diagnosis trepan
email algorithms from the public health
perspective this is an especially
relevant topic given the recent release
of updated Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention sexually transmitted
disease guidelines just a few weeks ago
my name is dr. Tiffany Mackenzie and I
am a scientific éclairs manager of
infectious disease and I'll be your
moderator for today's event you're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab leaks and
sponsored by the assign the diagnostic
specialist and global leader in in vitro
diagnostics worldwide you can find more
information about this Lauren @ww is on
dia SOR I am calm now we have a few
important announcements before we vision
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to
submit questions throughout the
presentation you can submit your
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button in the lower left-hand
corner of your presentation window we'll
try to answer as many of your questions
as we can and at any time you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the presentation window and if
you have any technical difficulty
hearing or viewing this presentation
please click the support button in the
top right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button in the lower left which I
just mentioned I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Richard
spiesse
who currently serves as the Certified
Public Health Laboratory director for
the state of Tennessee Department of
Health what this piece comes into this
role with over 30 years of experience
and is one of the nation's leading
Public Health Laboratory experts among
his multiple admirable roles thriving
public health initiatives in the UI
dr. sneeze has recently served as any
national committee a laboratory
coordinator for the CDC a science
advisor to the association of public
health laboratories athl and most
recently dr. speaks is the incoming
chair of the 2015's t v-- subcommittee
for aphl practice fees has worked at
every city county and state public
health laboratory in the nation and it
is our great pleasure to have you there
with us today and now i turn it over to
dr. space for the presentation Thank You
Tiffany that nice introduction and
before you started I'd actually like to
thank dias Oren for sponsoring the
presentation today and making it
possible for me to spend some time with
all of you the title of the presentation
today is simplest diagnosis Treponema
algorithms from the public health
laboratory perspective and if you can
see in the first slide first slide the
list of objectives we're gonna be
talking about more than just algorithms
we really need to talk about the signs
and the clinical disease the specific
tests and how they perform before we can
even talk about algorithms so what we're
going to try and do today we're going to
discuss the epidemiology of syphilis the
science of symptoms the clinical disease
and treatment so that we can better
understand syphilis screening and then
we're going to discuss the laboratory
tests that are available for syphilis
the advantages and their disadvantages
we're also going to talk about the
laboratory guidelines or or perhaps lack
of guidelines or at least the
recommendations that are currently
available for syphilis screening and the
necessity to perform at least two
independent laboratory syphilis test to
confirm the diagnosis of syphilis and
then we're going to be talking about the
different syphilis testing algorithms
and how those might apply to your
laboratory
in this light we can see that there's at
least three other subspecies of
Treponema pallidum pallidum or trouble
you McCallum they're known they're
rarely transmitted sexually or
congenitally they're responsible for
cutaneous or bone diseases and are
endemic to certain regions of the world
basil which is endemic in the Middle
East and North Africa Yas endemic in
Africa Asia and South America and Pinta
it's endemic in Latin America and well
why is it important that we know that
their subspecies the Treponema pallidum
well these subspecies actually do
cross-react with the trip specific trip
animal tests the ice thing so much about
being on trip animal tests having
specificity issues somewhat but the
Treponema tests also have some issues in
case language cross reactions and as we
know today anybody that's in the u.s.
can be in any country and then in just a
matter of a day or hours and somebody
that's in another country can be in the
u.s. so we may see individuals that have
lived in those countries or a visitor
those countries or had extended stays
here in the u.s. ending and it's helpful
to know some of the things that
potentially could cause false positives
in our trip any molasses there's other
things that might potentially cause
false positives and we'll talk about
them a little bit later in the
presentation
things like periodontal disease because
we all know the microflora in our mouths
contain a lot of spirochetes
and some of those can't cross react to
even in some of the most specific tests
that we have or syphilis
so it's just something to keep in mind
when we go through talking about the
diagnostic test and the specific test
syphilis are tripping in pallid
amorphous College up in the appellate or
for short use usually we don't use the
genus and subspecies and it's a
spirochete as we all know and because
it's a spirochete we know that it
doesn't steam with the usual
bacteriology stains it's sexually
transmitted as we all know and transmit
it transfers only to the newborn
untreated syphilis is marked by three
clinical stages the primary secondary
and tertiary stages that we've heard so
much about
spirochetes appear in the lesions and
right during the first two stages or the
clinical stages of syphilis syphilis is
susceptible of various chemical physical
agents it's a pretty wimpy michael
organisms as microorganisms go it's
extremely fastidious and sensitive they
eat cold drying disinfectants so high
accident intention and pH changes it
only survives minutes to a matter of a
few hours and bodies see creations and
it survives up to 36 hours in stored
blood we look at the site from the CDC
we can kind of look at syphilis and get
a little bit of a history of syphilis
and the reported cases by stage of
infection the total number of syphilis
cases you can see on the far left part
of this slide have gone down
significantly from the 40s and 50s well
part of that was the advent of
penicillin certainly and it was also
there then it was extremely aggressive
public health programs there were
hundreds of actually public health
officials disease intervention
specialists people actually wearing out
their shoe leather running down and
doing contact tracing so there was a
very aggressive program during these
years with many individuals involved to
start bringing these numbers down and
along with very good treatment and we
see the numbers continue to go down
until about the early 90s we see a
little blip and then the cases started
going out again but when we look at
about 2001 we see the cases starting to
drop a bit so the total number of cases
increased thirteen point one percent in
2012 and 2013 that real good news in the
next slide if we look at the primary and
secondary cases of syphilis the reported
cases by stage sex and sexual behavior
we see that ms/ms
account for a majority of the cases they
actually cover 75% of the cases in 2013
then you have sex with women or MSW the
cases of actually increased employment
the previous surveillance reports the
numbers have actually gone up a little
bit
women well we'll see in a minute remain
pretty much the same we look at the next
slide we can see the male to female rate
ratio has gone up the male rate has
continued to go up the total rate is
going up the female rate this written
remains fairly stable over the last 10
years or so that's kind of the good news
and the bad news the good news it has
gone up significantly but the bad news
is it hasn't gone down and when you look
at untreated early syphilis and pregnant
women it can result in prenatal
perinatal death up to 40 percent of the
cases so it is significant that we still
have syphilis around and it's something
that we really need to pay close
attention to from the public health
perspective all right let's talk a
little bit of the symptoms of syphilis
those will help us understand the
specific assays here that we'll get to
in a few minutes primary syphilis is
usually marked by a classic Shanker or
the painless Coleman sort that we see
from ten days to three months usually in
a period of two to six weeks the shake
is ordinarily painless
sometimes internal and oftentimes will
go unnoticed it's usually found on the
part of the body exposed to the bacteria
for example the penis the roll about the
vagina but the shaker can also develop
on the cervix the time lips or
fingertips as you can see in the lower
right hand part of this slide and it
self resolves or disappears within a few
weeks on its own and secondary syphilis
let me see the characteristic skin rash
somewhere in the range of two to twelve
weeks after the disappearance of the
initial Shanker when the shaker dries up
goes away skin rashes the next thing it
comes along and secondary syphilis this
rash may cover the entire body or it may
just appear in a few areas such as the
clumps of the hands or social defeat and
that'd be widely recognized and
secondary so that you might also see
that rash accompanied by new like
symptoms such as mild fever fatigue
headache sore throat as well as patchy
hair loss swollen lymph glands
throughout the body and other problems
you remember quite a few years ago we
used to cost surplus the great mimicker
that can mimic a lot of different
infectious diseases the secondary rash
of syphilis usually heals within weeks
to months and the other symptoms
gradually do subside all of these signs
and symptoms may occasionally come and
go over the next one to two years then
it moves on to tertiary syphilis where
we sit a major damage either starting to
or has already occurred to the heart and
to the eyes the brain the nervous system
the bones the joints are almost any part
of the body the stage can last for years
up to the lifetime of an individual
leading to the final stages of mental
illness blindness heart disease and even
death now keep in mind that we're
talking untreated syphilis looking at
these primary secondary and tertiary
stages of syphilis congenital syphilis
receive writing different symptoms may
see a nasal discharge skin eruptions
bone deprivation seizures nervous system
abnormalities premature birth
stillbirths and even death I put this
slide and this really gives a nice kind
of a graphic presentation where we've
just been talking about talking about
the infection the initial infection the
incubation period roughly two times and
the stages so keep this slide in mind
it's a little easier to look back at
this slide in your mind or in the
presentation when we start talking about
some of the non trouble any more trouble
any more tests and when we say that one
of the tests is more sensitive during
the primary stage or more specific
during the late tertiary stage this I
think this guide will really help us so
keep this in mind as we start talking
some of the specific tests for syphilis
uncomplicated treatment of syphilis
benzathine penicillin G 2.4 million
units
I am intramuscularly in a single dose
infants and children also benzathine
penicillin not not anything new the same
recommendations basically from the last
guidelines however we're just going to
talk about uncomplicated treatment basic
treatment here if you want more
information about treatment during
pregnancy treatment of individuals that
are allergic to penicillin what to do
the new laboratory guidelines for CDC
are just published June 5th so the sex
of transmitted disease Gala is for 2015
are available you can go to the URL on
this slide you can download these you
can go on the website and look up
anything you want to look up at any time
you can actually order nice hard copies
and they have wall charts that you can
get and other resources so I encourage
you to go onto the CDC website because
it has a lot of good information about
syphilis treatment as well as streaming
for the rest of the STDs okay let's move
on to syphilis laboratory methods the
diagnosis looking at the direct test we
don't see too many these direct tests
around anymore those of you there around
for a few years probably know that we
used to do a lot of dark field tests
like microscope dark field condenser you
should take a chancre take scraping put
on a slide and do a dark field if we got
a positive dark field
I'm stag Matic for syphilis and we would
treat the individuals very useful test
however it's a little bit difficult you
have to maintain paint some expertise to
do dark fields that have the easiest
thing in the world to do and if you're
doing like one a month you're not doing
enough and so when the syphilis numbers
started dropping and in some areas of
the country you know we really didn't
have syphilis or certainly a lot of
stuff us anymore dark field eventually
started going away because it was very
difficult to maintain that expertise so
there's very difficult to find a site
that's even performing dark fields
anymore
direct fluorescent antibody assay I came
along kind of at the tail end of the
dark field it's a good asset it's more
sensitive than in the dark field but it
required a base coat and of course
there's an expensive bother than that
and some expertise just keeping the
slope aligned let alone and doing the
procedures so both techniques very
difficult to bind any sites or even
doing those nowadays the nucleic acid
amplified tests or ecr's there's
currently no FDA cleared test available
talked to several manufacturers and a
lot of individuals on the the SE
committee and other individuals have
have talked with a diagnostic many
factors to try and encourage someone to
come out with it with a good molecular
assay or PCR it would be very helpful
very useful to the clinicians to try and
differentiate some of the shakers or
potential shakers or is it really a
chancre when somebody comes in with the
soldiers at a chancre is that a bet sort
of is that a bug bite is that an
atypical herpes lesion
what is it so the test would be very
useful actually in in a clinical field
too to have available can also be very
useful with in case of neurosyphilis
looking at CSF and a congenital syphilis
so we have very powerful tests they have
available and certainly would be
utilized quite a bit and it's more
sensitive than the dark field in the DNA
serological diagnosis there's two
separate categories as we know of tests
for syphilis than entrepreneurial
category that are primarily or were
primarily used the screening tests and
are still used and useful for monitoring
the efficacy of treatment we know that
in our PR for example over time and we
monitor that and it was being treated
that those studies are expected to fall
somewhere between six months to a year
and usually completely disappear with
successful treatment trouble needle
tests are generally more sensitive and
specific than the non trepan all tests
may increase your positive predictive
value of your reactants are positive
truck neva Springs and as everyone knows
when you're reacting with the Treponema
ya say
you generally relaxed reacted for life
the exceptions but generally are
reactive for life okay we've got a
couple tables on to take a look at and I
think this is important to know some of
the limitations of these assays and this
table is just a guide it certainly
didn't include everyone in the video all
versions are periodic tests under the
Sun but it's representative of those
groups and we can see when we talked
about primary suppress if you look back
in your mind or look back in the slide
set if you have those primary secondary
syphilis
the flow of the clinical symptoms and
the disease this will help you kind of
place what we're talking about here so
in primary syphilis the natural animal
tests are not bad but they're not as
sensitive as you'll see a few minutes a
strep animal test said you can kind of
get a range of those and you get a range
because there's a lot of different
manufactures and a lot of different ways
these studies were designed and set up
but when you do a meta-analysis and you
look at it they are that you have a lack
of sensitivity in the primary stage
where you can see in the secondary stage
most you're not trouble you know tests
do very well and in your latent stage
that you fairly well but very late
syphilis they may be some issues or some
problems and specificity while they all
look like they're in the high 90s if you
remember back even at a 98% specificity
if you're screening in a low prevalence
population you're going to add more
false father's so it's something to keep
in mind the Treponema last days and we
again look at primary syphilis and from
the previous slide you can see that
they're more sensitive in the primary
stage now this table was put together a
little while ago and and we didn't have
many years at that time when it was put
together and the CLIA isn't even
included but it appears that the EIS and
the CLA tests are are more sensitive
than the
other technical tests that that we have
currently available in primary syphilis
so we'll talk a little bit more about
that when we start talking about
specific trumpeting tests but they
certainly are more sensitive in the
secondary and and for latent syphilis
and for late simplest you remember right
late syphilis that the RP r had some
difficulties with sensitivity and
they're very specific assays in addition
to their sensitivity now let's look at
some of the specific tests non-trump
animal tests that are PR tests i think
one of the first companies that came out
with an RBI test I believe was probably
be an excellent RP our tests still a
good test as other manufacturers that
make our PR tests there they're all good
tests the ones that are certainly in the
u.s. they've all been FDA cleared the
prl tests basically the first test for
screening microscopic s versus the RP
our test was a mattress topically with
your eye but the PDL is still used for
spinal fluids and that's one of the main
reasons that we that we keep the VDRL
that trust sa again just a little
modification of the RP are instead of
charcoal particles that are caught in
the antibody complex and cause of
flocculation and you can actually see
the charcoal particles they use a a
telling mean red dye they actually is
captured now again it's a nice little
test that just kind of a different
version of our PR and point of care test
they debated whether I wanted to even
talk about the point-of-care tests but I
mentioned it for two reasons one we have
no non Treponema point-of-care test
strip here cleared in the u.s. there are
non trip animal tests that are used
throughout the world and we do have one
manufacturer in the u.s. that's working
on a point-of-care test that has an
entrepeneur ana Treponema ban you know
and hopefully one of these days we'll
see that products submitted FDA and
anyway maybe see it available in the
market but at this point in time no non
trepan e120 care tests available in the
u.s. truck Nimal tests our old friend
the FDA the TPP a good assays the inside
memo on sa is in this variety different
animal assays the chemo luminescent MSA
the last on you can see the instrument a
lot of right hand side of the slide
point-of-care tests we do have one point
of care test one Treponema point-of-care
tests that's fda cleared in the US and
that's marketed by trinity this time
it's actually a product that's made in
france and it's a way of des a so that
is currently available we'll talk a
little bit about that later and then of
course the bio-rad micro the amino acid
MV i just kind of refresh our memory a
little bit about the RP are really get
specimens in and this will be important
when we talk about algorithms but we'll
get to let's say 10 10 individuals we
have 10 10 bloods that we spend down the
serum so we take and we'll put 10
individual serums on on this slide one
in each spot so we have 10 people we're
testing here well in our engine that the
chart go with the ante with a deep heart
extract because basically what we're
looking for is anti cardiolipin
antibodies are PR test does not major
specific antibodies to the trepan ii the
trip animo sa major specific antibodies
the RP arc test does not so that's one
of the issues with the specificity
problems so if we get a reactive and you
can see on the slide here about the
slides are really difficult to look at
and there is some subjectivity or
reading that the cart test obviously you
need to read it under incandescent light
source not a fluorescent source but a
nice incandescent ball
and you can rotate it back and forth
those are you read these know exactly
what I'm talking about
and you look for that regulation that
clumping that a nation look if you will
the charcoal particles the charcoal
particles and specimen number seven
looks and the slide looks at reacted a
couple of them do look reactive here to
they're kind of fuzzy it's kind of hard
to tell but what we'll do is when we get
a reactive one like let's say number
seven and then little take and go to the
art P R quantitative and you see the
quanta an example the quantitative essay
right below that will take that specimen
and will dilute it out there that one
two two four eight sixteen all the way
out to five twelve and we'll look for an
end point and you can see from this
slide the slide again it's not like
reading it right into the light but and
the slide looks like the input might be
somewhere around thirty two possibly
over to sixty four-bit
but it shows that much better than you
actually looking at it than it than it
does certainly being rejected here but
let's say it's 1 to 32 that's where the
last will you see a positive so your
last positive was at a dilution of of
132 so your titer is 32 remember that
the titer is just reciprocal of the
dilution so when you going to look back
because it's our 32 that means that was
reactive or positive out to a dilution
of 132 and we utilize this test to
monitor the efficacy of the treatment
that I just mentioned before next that
the slide is the TPPA assay I get a nice
little assay that uses a little gelatin
particles that are coated with the
antigen we had the patient's specimen
and we have antibodies so we get nice
agglutination and you can see that i'm
sensitized particles for controls and
the sensitized particles with the
antigen patient serum and the gluten
nation it's it's a fairly simple assay
and and it works fairly well
and it's really so this certainly is
some subjectivity to reading then the
next one it's our old friend again the
FTA been around for a long time very
good assay we have the trêpa names upon
a slide but the agent serum on if
there's antibodies they'll attach to the
trebonius specific antibodies measuring
specific Treponema antibodies with your
trip any molasses and we put our anti
human conjugate conjugated with
fluorescein and we'll see nice bright
and glowing trebonius in the case
individuals that have antibodies to
syphilis nice positive FTA okay they're
not tripping in molasses let's take a
look at the advantages and disadvantages
of those the advantages in art they're
fairly sensitive through most of the
areas of syphilis
except for as you can see over in the
disadvantage lower sensitivity and
primary infection it's important to keep
in mind when we start talking about
algorithms so high sensitivity except in
that primary infection they're fairly
rapid low cost doesn't detect past
infection this requires little equipment
testing couple rotators covers pipe
editors saying saline not much just
really needed to run our be ours as a
matter of fact the RP are rich and it
was developed as a field si very little
card that individuals actually we're
running on the field and they would just
use their hands instead of a rotator to
rotate it around so that they could
treat patients right on the spot user
requires only one reflex test as we know
you do an art PR you go on to trumpeting
Lassa and usually that gives you some
kind of an answer to take some kind of
an action and it's useful for treatment
monitoring again we want to look for
that antibody titer to be going down
with treatment
so the disadvantage as well better
because it's not it doesn't measure
specific antibodies it has some false
positives there are other things that
can cause false positives with non-trump
Nimal assays and lower sensitivity
during primary infection that we talked
about it's somewhat labor-intensive
you've got a lot of cards you've got
like a lot of pipetting to do and
subjective results you can see you're
looking at the issue reading these
sometimes the results aren't real clear
and there's other things that can cause
some issues excess antibody or pros
Olmec back then is some of the things
that can cause problems that that we
know that we're working with and those
are you done are be ours so there are
some issues and problems manual data
manipulations if you've got specimens on
a form you're transferring those from a
worksheet over to a card from a card to
your computer there's a lot of
manipulations and there certainly could
be potential for error in your
translations you Treponema screening
well advantageous it's very sensitive
and it's very specific
there's objective results in the case of
the EIA is a CLIA is as you can see the
FDA and the TPPA
are not objective they're subjective you
have to read those but there's the newer
assays very objective results read by an
instrument automation high-throughput
you can interface these with electronic
information systems they can also be
used as a confirmatory test as can alter
penile tests and they can uses a large
volume of screening assay using the
reverse algorithm or alternate algorithm
if you will and we're going to talk
about this reverse how the rhythm when
we get
further down in the presentation the
disadvantages they can't distinguish
between active and previously treated
disease again once your reacted with the
tremana Treponema test you're generally
reactive for life so if you were
screening with just a trip animal assay
that would create a potential for
overdiagnosis and overtreatment and it
might require more resources for
investigations our disease intervention
specialists Rd ISS would have to follow
up more people that we were screening
solely with at repeting lass a and there
may be specific costly instruments tied
to some of these some of the newer
Treponema tests if you have to buy a new
piece of equipment and well there's not
many pieces of equipment that are cheap
these tests so it's probably going to be
questioned
those things need to be factored in now
some manufacturers again who Rachel
Reynolds and you had a few pennies to a
nickel to a dime to the test and you
have the instruments so these are things
to look at and just things to be aware
of when you determine the cost and how
and what you're going to use to screen
for syphilis they also might require
multiple reflex tests for resolving
discrepancies if we're talking in the
reversal algorithm and we're going to
more detail on that in just a few
minutes okay so you could you remember
back in the slide one of the first or
second slide shown the CDC slides
syphilis is really really cal threat and
around 2001 in those caves rates have
steadily increased overall increase
since then efforts to eliminate syphilis
are apparently falling short the current
state of laboratory diagnosis may be a
contributing factor reaching populations
that we should be reaching in aren't
certainly could be a factor too but if
we look at the laboratory Diagnostics
perspective it may be because we have
limited access to direct detection if we
had a good direct detection method such
as a PCR it might really help the
program
to address the situation with these
rising syphilis rates and we have a
heavy reliance on the serological based
assets and as you know strategies are
basically in demand evidence of their
body so they're kind of an indirect
evidence if you will of syphilis or
prior Sluis infections they require a
normal immune response and they're just
expressed or individuals that have HIV
the response isn't always the same as it
is in normal individuals and there's
nonspecific and false negative reactions
and we know what causes some of those
but we don't have all the answers so
there are some problems with the
approaches that we're currently taking
to try and reduce syphilis in the u.s.
so the need for laboratory guidance well
when CDC provides guidelines they
influenced both public health laboratory
and the clinical laboratory practice a
very influential they usually address
the appropriate use of these tests or a
variety of tests you talking about
syphilis in this case and test
performance the test performance is
dependent upon the states the syphilis
infection and what about the HIV
co-infection either things that
guidelines could help address test
interpretation need for reflex testing
they need for repeat tests and
additional specimens it would be really
nice to have some national guidance to
provide answers to some of these
questions that come up in the
laboratories
well CDC did take an attempt at that in
January 2009 there was an expert
consultation it was held was actually
held concurrent with the committee and
gonorrhea expert consultation just down
the hall and multiple areas at that time
were discussed it with the syphilis
experts direct detection of Treponema
pallidum or syphilis things like PCR and
dark field etc congenital syphilis use
of IgM or other tests to detect
congenital syphilis
neurosyphilis what tests could we use
what tests could we use
to differentiate other entities from
from syphilis and serology well that
information from that expert
consultation is available it's on the
APHA website and the URL is listed at
the bottom so you can go on and you can
find those recommendations that were put
on the website about a month after the
or lesson about that for the expert
consultation and if you forget the URL
or don't have access to that if you just
go onto athl dot or website you can you
longer infectious diseases under STD e
and you can go in and find this as well
as other documents that are very useful
to individuals that are performing STI
our STD testing and screening we're just
going to talk about syphilis and aspects
that were discussed at that expert
consultation today some of the things
that were discussed there was a lot of
talk about the enzyme immunoassays an
enzyme in when I say is some of them
hadn't been around too long so keep in
mind in 2009 there's been more
information that's come along since then
but at that time and it was determined
that most of the EIS performed equally
well for screening those that detected
both IgM and IgG appeared to be a little
bit more sensitive an early disease
there was a limited head-to-head
comparison beta available especially
with the clinical luminescent Imanol
assays and microsphere although the data
at the time suggested that the CLIA
actually was the most sensitive of the
Treponema assays that were currently
available at that time
there's also variability in the
performance of the different trip animal
tests as you know they do to the the
antigens of the test the conjugates the
proprietary methods of assembling these
tests so there are variety different
things and there was some variability
however even with that variability the
overall agreement between the Treponema
tests well she's a greater than 95
percent even in primary disease now
that's not the complete whole picture
and we're going to talk about that
again in a few minutes we talk about
algorithms or something that sometimes
we frequently miss when we're talking
about that even though they perform
fairly well and fairly equal there are
some differences so we'll talk about
okay so the questions that came up with
a serializable response following
successful treatment of syphilis
infection was really unclear based on on
treatment in stage if somebody's treated
very early what happens so logically we
do know that was successful treatment
that the RP r generally goes away but
what happens to the long term effect of
the trip any neural tests if they're
treated very early as it disappeared if
they're treated later and secondary
syphilis it appears that it doesn't so
there's a lot of unanswered questions
about really what happens with these
serological assays and then if
individuals are screen in the future how
do we interpret some of that so there
were a lot of questions that were raised
also interestingly most biological false
positive reactions with the natural
animal end Treponema were generally seen
in the serie of quote healthy
individuals at least individuals that
appeared healthy no external signs of
any disease or infectious disease and at
that time the clinicians felt that that
data did not support the pregnant women
have a higher rate of biological false
positives and that's really interesting
because I remember all the cases false
positive results that we used to get in
pregnant when and when I heard this it
cost the laboratories to kind of start
thinking a little bit and looking at
this and and while we used to see a lot
of these biological false positives the
clinicians one of the things they would
say is well I don't know why sent the
specimen in anyway they say well you
know what you don't want to know if the
answer don't send it in to ask the
question and we deal with a lot of
individuals that had these are PRS they
were most likely false positives we had
some other tests and some other methods
so we worked with CDC on at that time
that would help determine that but to be
on the safe side we really didn't have
enough information and the clinician was
going to treat they generally had no
choice in treating and you're not going
to treat a pregnant woman if you can't
get it didn't answer of whether this is
a true positive or not but I think the
reason that these stood out is because
we had so so few of them they weren't
pregnant women so that was it's really
interesting that that because that used
to be kind of a common misconception
among laboratorians that pregnant women
have a higher rate of biological
positive what turns out it's just that
we notice those and have to deal with
those more often but that's not really
truly the case and the hair rates an
elderly may point to periodontal disease
is a cause of biological false positives
and we talked about that earlier about
the spirochetes
in the mouth and that's one of the
reasons when we do a dark field we don't
do a dark field from any oral lesions
because there's other spirochetes the
spirochetes from an oral lesion is not
necessarily diagnostic for syphilis
versus in the on the penis it certainly
is so one thing to remember from our
dark field days okay if we go on and
look at some of the other
recommendations that were made the
selections of specific tests or
screening depends on the prevalence of
the disease in the population the
purpose of the test whether you're gonna
use it for screening or confirmation the
subjectivity of the test and the
experience of the technologist the
equipment the costs etc these are all
things that should go into the
consideration when you're looking at
syphilis laboratory methods the ones
you're currently using and evaluating
more than what you're looking at may be
moving into and more than one algorithm
may be necessary when using the nod trip
animal test is the initial screen which
most of us are very familiar with that's
so called traditional screening method
and when using a trip animal test is the
initial screen even if we're using the
trip animal test as an initial screen we
probably started use
Matt Trapani will test at one point in
time unless her really new
microbiologists so a combination of
Treponema and non Trapani will test must
be used whether you're using a
traditional or the reverse algorithm a
single trip anneal test cannot be relied
upon for syphilis diagnosis this was a
little algorithm that was put together
by dr. Becky cool I think he actually
worked at CDC see with this publication
how in 2004 and she made some
recommendations talked about the
traditional testing algorithm using the
non trended Treponema tests or initial
screen and you can see the night renewal
test at the top the RTR ppl trust and it
was not in react even this simplified
out of the rhythm a doctor folks that
you know probably not syphilis or
perhaps early syphilis it offered a
little bit of a further explanation if
it was reactive of course we all know
that we go to the the tighter we tie to
this best without and then we reflux
that to a trap animal test and
historically traditionally that's been
FDA and EPA now those could bei is here
CLIA is perhaps even a point-of-care
test Treponema test so a trepang you
know test for a reflex test this
nonreactive
it was suggested in this algorithm and
it was a false positive not repeatable
test certainly can be could be true but
it was nonreactive you remember that in
primary syphilis you know there are some
issues and there's issues with false
positivity so it was a reactive with
syphilis and three very straightforward
not a lot of detail on it the alternate
or the reverse algorithm the testing
algorithm using GIS or CLIA as the
initial screen if it's reactive we kind
of go reverse and we do it in an email
test
or tie to that specimen out and
depending upon the results if we get a
positive it would be consistent with
syphilis if it's negative it was
suggested that we run Treponema test
that uses a different antigens or a
platform from a different manufacturer
okay now here's the situation when we
have Treponema lasses where they all
performed fairly well fairly good sense
sensitivities on all of those assays we
know that some definitely perform a
little bit others better than others and
the data that we had at the time of
course done that on the CLIA
indicated it was more sensitive test so
if we scream let's say with CLIA you can
see the problem coming here and we got a
negative or positive and or negative
then we had to do to repeat tripping
evil test and we screamed with the test
that was less sensitive we're gonna get
a negative so you're screening with the
test you're confirming if you will
attest it's less sensitive than a better
test you're screening with so there's
some potential problems and you need to
keep these things and you need to be
aware of these things when you're using
these screening assays so there needs to
be more guidance and we're going to talk
about that more guidance in just a
couple minutes one thing to remember no
matter what algorithm you're using if
you're using multiple assets in this
particular case the laboratory should
report the results of all three essays I
have to get in a regulatory and if we do
three different assays we're obligated
regularly from the regulatory agency to
report the results of all those three
essays so that's one thing to remember
too okay let's talk a little bit about
the traditional algorithm well it
detects active infection usually fairly
well there's a high rate of biological
false positives we use the trip animo
test as a confirmation test if you will
that's what we we called it
confirmation test the use of both of
these tests a positive result a high
positive predictive value but we
certainly can miss early primary or
treated infections the reverse algorithm
detects early primary and treated
infections that might be missed with the
traditional screening the night retinal
test is still needed to detect that
active infection and also monitoring
that efficacy of treatment the EIA and
CLIA and other tribunal tests have
higher specificity than the non trip
animal tests so very good assays okay so
why are laboratory switching to chemo
luminescent mo assays and and some new
assays well the advantages there they're
automated they're really great for high
throughput so if you have staffing
issues you know it's really nice to be
more automated they're low cost and high
volume settings of course most tests
that larger the volume the more
efficient the test is objective results
they're read with an instrument and some
of the tests may be technicai Gigi and
IgM and potentially more positives and
early syphilis depending on their
conjugates also some of the
manufacturers are working on and
probably will have some specific IgM
tests available which might be very
useful to differentiate some the primary
cases of syphilis from a past infection
some of the disadvantages you can't
distinguish currently between these
active disease and old disease studies
comparing the test performance against
these others head-to-head comparisons we
don't have a lot of those we need more
information and more head to head
comparisons so it can be confusing
sometimes to manage these phases with
the discrepant serology you get a
positive
ew a a negative our PA our curfew our
what do you do
what type of recommendations can be made
well the association of public health
laboratories the infectious disease
committee specifically the STD
subcommittee has been working on a
variety of educational materials some
training modules for syphilis as well as
some suggested reporting language for
syphilis diagnostic testing algorithms
and they have pretty much a final draft
of this the finalized version will be
available as I mentioned later this
summer and it'll look pretty much like
what you see here this is just the top
portion of that we've got the nine
trepan emote about that or the
traditional algorithm at the top and in
that if you look at step one a you'll
see that the RP r and in this particular
case it's nonreactive
so the Apollo up would not be indicated
chubba Nemo sa would be not indicated
and what would be that interpretation to
the left trigger for what for the
actions might you want to take now this
sheet again it's just the top this is
going to be this will be a one-page
sheet and it's going to cover the rest
it's going to cover that the next step
would be reactive or weekly reactive
tripling will react at terminal
nonreactive
all the different possible combinations
that we might see with traditional
testing there's going to be an
interpretation a suggested
interpretation for laboratory reporting
and further action recommendations to
provide some guidance to individuals in
the field that are using have a
non-traditional testing methodology and
in addition some of the rare situations
will be covered that
get an individual and older individual
with hearing loss and an audiologist so
want to send that in to see if I might
be related to a syphilis case where he
might ask us to do he or she might ask
us to do just a trumpet email and say
some of the strange requests that we
might occasionally get to to support
specific requests from clinicians and
and public companies so it would cover
all the standards as well as some of the
rare and unusual with these
interpretations and further actions so
it'll be a very good document and
certainly very timely we also have the
reverse algorithm you can see on the
bottom and again it's just the top row
because this hasn't been finalized yet
but this non-reactive are pretty
straightforward similar the language you
know we're working on finalizing the
language but it'll be a one-page thing
or will have the CIA's claa SMI A's and
if they're not only active the next
quantitative rep unites indicated
revenue Bethesda indicated no lab trail
but that's a syphilis infection etc so
we'll see one page again of all the
different combinations that you possibly
could see when you're testing using the
non-traditional or when you're using the
reverse algorithm so those should be
available later this summer aphl when
they're available I'm sure we'll put
them in their newsletter they'll
probably send them out certainly do that
to the public health sector if any
individuals want to get a copy of these
or want to know more about it you can
certainly contact me you have my contact
information with the presentation or you
can contact and Gainor at aphl and just
say hey when these are available would
you let me know and I'm sure they'd be
glad to refer you to the site that you
could download a copy or provide a copy
for you
so you can ask me and I'll put you on a
less - and they're available or I get an
Gator and so less on aphl with the STD
subcommittee and has done a lot of work
to keep the the committee on track and
to produce these documents so there's
going to be some nice resources that are
going to be available very shortly for
laboratories to use son conclusion the
guidelines from CDC would be helpful to
the laboratories to be really nice to
get some guidelines from CDC in the
meantime the proceedings from the
syphilis expert consultation are
available they the clinical and public
health laboratories on the aphl website
BPA channel will make a document
available per laboratories on the
suggested reporting language for
syphilis diagnostic testing algorithms
later this summer and more studies are
actually needed to try and answer some
of the questions that didn't get
answered at the work group and some of
those questions are do we have a need is
there a need for gold standard lastly a
Western flat or a pseudo bladder RIBA
something like that do we need it do we
need something like that to
differentiate between one positive truck
needle test and a negative test or two
positives and I'm not repeating we'll
test some kind of a reference referee
standard of some sort is that necessary
there's a need for serum Bank of
well-characterized Sarah differentiated
by a clinical stage for research aphl is
actually in the process of putting
together surveying for its members right
now there's a need for a comprehensive
study to compare the Treponema and the
night ripening lastly is currently FDA
cleared in the u.s. using Syrah from all
stages of syphilis and the role of the
point-of-care tests in the syphilis
algorithm and screening it's a trump
animal test is there a role for the the
point-of-care test and the point-of-care
tests that may be coming out what would
be their role so a lot of unanswered
questions a lot of questions and
research still to come so at this point
I'd like to end the presentation
and if there's any questions I'll be
glad to try and answer thank you and
have a good day thank you dr. Seif for
that informative presentation before we
get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window and
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
and before we get started on the
questions I just want to relay the
results of our poll so thank you so much
to everybody who responded and so the
laboratory poll question was if your
laboratory currently performs syphilis
testing which algorithm do you run the
traditional algorithm such as screening
with an entrepreneurial test our PR VDRL
and confirming with an entrepreneurial
tests such as CIA or CLIA and 48% of the
respondents answered to that or did your
laboratory run the reverse algorithm and
24 percent of respondents chose that
answer or 27 percent of respondents
chose not applicable so thank you so
much to everybody who participated in
the poll and now we will move on to our
first question
so dr. theis after blood collection what
is the maximum recommended time to add
on this test if it's missed at the time
of that when the test is requested okay
not exactly sure and so we'll take a
stab at this here I think the question
you're asking if blood specimen comes in
and they didn't request syphilis how
long do you have before you can use that
specimen and test it for syphilis if
that's not the question you'll get back
to me but that's that's the way I
interpret this remember when you're
staying in a specimen you're sending in
a blood specimen and you know for
syphilis serologies the special is very
stable so there's really not like for
some of our other direct antigen test
for yet you know six hours 12 hours 24
hours that we have if they can test if
the samples not good serums you know
should be good at the laboratory that
you submitted to submitted it to as long
as it's been stored properly for
probably as long as they're going to
keep most your private labs don't keep
specialist very long and the public
health lab you know they keep it around
for depending on us and infor so you
know your serum specimens going to be
stable and you know we can pull these
out you know for a lot of our
retrospective studies you know do our
serology so you know there's not really
generally an issue with the stability of
that specimen so you still have time if
for some reason you wanted order
syphilis tests on that specimen that
came in
okay great thank you and our next
question who is the manufacturer who are
some potential manufacturers working on
an entrepreneur MOU or point-of-care
trip animal tests in the u.s. that
you're aware of well the manufacturer
that's working on it that I'm aware of
there may be several others but actually
Kim buyouts they have a nice little
product and you know they're yeah you
know anybody can buy you might want to
talk to them and see where they're at
with that and see if they you know can
talk them into submitting it to FDA and
trying to get this into fdn get at your
clearance it's a-you know looks like
pretty good little assay and the
performance early performance and I'm
looking very good in so hopefully
they'll get an FDA before too long and
it may be available excellent
and our next question um so looking at
so which their conversion occurs first
that from our PR or from a trip in you
know specific syphilis IgM test that
you're aware of or it has studies maybe
not been done to address that yet you
know that's up until fairly recently
we've had suppose a GM tests available
for a long period of time most of the
simple steps that we used a few years
ago
we're not FDA approved and some of them
didn't really work too well so I don't
think we really do have a good answer to
that question of what syphilis IgM tests
whether that comes up before they are PR
or not I don't know the answer to that
question anyway so we do need more work
and certainly in that area good question
excellent and the recapping on what role
you expect if any that molecular testing
could play in the diagnosis of syphilis
okay again a very good question that
mean that I mention during the
presentation I think it'd be really
great to have a molecular test to
directly detect it was from unknown
chambers into our sores that potentially
could be Shanker's it could be confused
with Shanker's and CSF as we mentioned
cases of congenital syphilis with
darkfield essentially no longer
available I think it'd be a real asset
to our public health efforts to control
syphilis by having this kind of a
point-of-care test if you will we have
an FDA cleared molecular test for
influenza so the next step certainly
could be a nice test for syphilis so I
hope the manufacturers are all listening
and I hope somebody's very actively
pursuing that I think we I think we
really need that
following up on well I guess that about
concludes our time for today
doctor seats were there any other
closing remarks that you might have had
no other than you know there's still
some questions here I'll take a look at
the questions and that there's contact
information or if you want to glue
contact information if you did I'll be
glad to answer those personally so thank
you very much for the opportunity and I
hope everybody has a good day okay um so
thank you I just want to thank you again
so much to do Soren for making today's
educational webcast possible and this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through six months from today or
until December 25th 2015 you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay and we invite you to forward
this announcement to your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event so
see you next time and thank you so much